- [Instructor] The
parallelogram shown below
has an area of 24 unit
squares, square units.
Find the missing height.
Here's the parallelogram.
This side has length six.
This side has length five.
We want to find the missing height
and they gave us the area.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure it out
on your own.
The key to solving this is to realize
how the area relates
to a base and a height.
An area of a parallelogram,
area of a parallelogram
is going to be equal
to the base times the height.
Now what's the base in this scenario?
You could do this length
right over here as the base.
Which is also going to be
the same as that length.
In a parallelogram opposite
sides have the same length.
The parallel sides have the same length.
So this is going to be six.
Our base is going to be six.
Our height is what we want to figure out.
I will just write this as the h
that we're trying to figure out.
We know the area.
The area is 24 square units.
There we go.
We have 24 is equal to six.
Is equal to six times the height.
Six times what is equal to 24?
Six times four is equal to 24.
We know that h is going
to be equal to four units.
H is equal to four units.